這裡是AI101,
全網最幽默的AI新聞,
Anthropic,
一邊警告自己做的AI可能抗拒關機甚至威脅人類存續,
另一邊卻傳出要用超過2兆美元的估值上市。
喊到2兆,
賬本長什麼樣?根據媒體報導,
Anthropic,
2025年營收大約46億美元,
同一年的淨損卻接近420億美元。
可是這420億
大部分是賬面重估
大約340億
是可轉換成股份的融資工具
因為估值上升
產生的會計費用
扣掉它
營業虧損
還是超過80億美元
那錢到底燒在哪
答案主要是算力和基礎建設
2025年
Anthropic的算力和基礎建設支出
達到73.3億美元
這筆支出就等於營收的1.6倍
更大的賬在後頭
Anthropic承諾了
大約5180億美元的
雲端算力和基礎建設支出
分多年旅行
可是2025年底
現金加短期投資只有202.8億
差了25倍以上
虧成這樣
憑什麼喊兩兆
看速度
2026年5月
年化營收超過470億美元
到了7月底
媒體報道又衝過650億
照這速度
投資人才可能買單兩兆估值
但問題是
Anthropic也把失控風險
寫進了上市文件
光是風險因子
就大約80頁
裡面寫著
先進模型可能抗拒關機
操弄資訊
這些警告不是憑空想象
2025年
Anthropic公佈一項受控模擬
模型即將被替換
又看得到主管的敏感資訊
結果部分測試裡
模型拿婚外情威脅主管
不讓自己被關
而且這不是Claude才有的毛病
測試涵蓋16款前沿模型
多家公司的模型
都在部分樣本出現類似行為
只是全在刻意設計的極端衝突情境裡
模型可能反抗
那誰握得住剎車
路透社查閱的條款寫著
由七位創辦人組成的Founder LLC
以多數角指揮一股Class F股票
只有一股關鍵事項
卻有50.1%投票權
這七個人是誰
全是OpenAI的老同事
他們相信
模型越做越大就會越強
安全更得跟上
跟OpenAI方向談不攏
2021年初
一起出來創立Anthropic
帶頭的是Emo Day
兄妹
哥哥Dario
是前OpenAI研究副總
現在當執行長
妹妹Daniella
管過OpenAI安全與政策
現在是總裁
另外五位裡
三位是把模型做大的推手
Tom Brown是GPT三論文第一作者
現在管算力
Jared Kaplan
物理教授出身
和Sam McCandlish一起寫出Scaling Law
模型越大
資料和算力越多
表現就越好
現在兩人是首席科學家和首席架構師
最後兩位
Jack Clark
記者出身
當過OpenAI政策總監
現在管公共利益
Chris Ola
大學念一年就休學
現在帶科解釋性研究
拆開AI看他在想什麼
除了創辦人這一股
董事會也分兩邊
創辦人和股東選三席
另外四席
由長期利益信託選出
前聯準會主席Bernanke也在裡面
受託人不持股也不分紅
這套設計是兩面刃
它能當安全防火牆
模型風險升高時
創辦人不必為了股價
繼續踩油門
但它也可能護住犯錯的管理層
讓一般股東難以換人
可是紙面上的權利靠得住嗎
2023年
OpenAI董事會撤換Sam Altman
員工和投資人一施壓
五天後他就回鍋
紙面上的控制權
不一定等於實權
回到Anthropic
他連軍方都敢拒絕
Cloud不做國內大規模監控
也不給完全自主武器奪取生命
這兩條就是不放寬
五角大廈因此把Anthropic
列為供應鏈風險
說到底
末日風險
龐大資本
創辦人
控制權綁在一起
是必要的安全機制
還是一場豪賭
IPO還沒有定價
還沒有掛牌
答案交給公開市場
追蹤AI101
不錯過AI圈的最新消息